I did that for the first time when I did
Thursday night football half times on
NBC tournament I turned my left the NBC
a little bit a little bit of a nod and
all the Howard Stern fans were sweet at
me that seemed if I had no idea if my
colleagues at the time knew what I was
up to was Rodney Harrison it was Tony
Dungy of football night in America a Pro
Football Hall of Famer and one of my my
favorite people have gotten a meet in
this business now here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Tony I appreciate that
Tony I greatly appreciate that how are
you doing I saw you and uh your wife
your son bicycling on your Twitter
handle your Twitter feed the other day
everybody okay out there unexpected
blessings my son is 28 years old now
real estate business and we don't get to
spend a lot of time together but he's
got time off now we've got time during
the day and we can get out and ride so
that's been fun we've got eight young
kids still in the house though so we're
doing oh my gosh virtual learning and
online and I'm learning about all these
apps that our kids have has been
different learning tools so I'm getting
an education for sure and I'm sure your
your your legendary patience my kids in
the last week than I did probably with
my payment you know it's all about
motivating it's all about coaching it's
all about obviously you know parenting
these days Tony Dungy here on the Rich
Eisen show what what has been however
obviously you can't go about town I even
saw in your tweet there that you
included about letting everyone know
that you were doing proper social
distancing but that's that that said
what is the sense that you get about
Brady signing in Tampa there's been
unbelievable everyone is just hoping we
have a season and things get back to
normal because the excitement and the
level of expectation now is through the
roof people have always been excited
about Buccaneers football and and and
that but this off
and no one expected this and people
can't wait so how do you think the
Arians Brady marriage is going to go
down I think it's gonna be very good I
think tom is going to elevate the play
of a lot of the guys around and they've
got two talented people here I think
burst has done a good job of putting
together some defensive people that can
can create some havoc Todd Bowles is
very creative on that side of the ball
and offensively they've got some skill
positions you know everybody's
complained about Tom Brady's weapons the
last few years they have weapons here
and in the passing game tight ends wide
receivers Pro Bowlers you know and
Thomas John is gonna be stirring the
drink so III think they're going to be
good I think Bruce has worked with a lot
of quarterbacks in you look at what he
did with Carson Palmer and when Carson
was in his late thirties I think he
knows how to put together a quarterback
from the off well in terms of Ariens you
know on this I love stories like this
because you know obviously there's
coaching trees coaching lineages and
coaching relationships that I'd like to
always put a spotlight on you and
earrings did you guys share an apartment
when you work for Schottenheimer back in
the day we did Bruce had been the head
coach at Temple he went to Kansas City
as a running back coach I went there as
defensive backfield coach right our both
of our families weren't coming until
June we're trying to get housing squared
away so January to June we shared an
apartment and we were roommates for six
months and it was pretty awful is it is
it safe to say you were the clean one he
was the messy one
[Laughter]
but we had a good time we really did we
came very it came very close and had
three wonderful years together on that's
their dad I bet yeah and Aryans just
again he's just an old-school guy that
again obviously who's very demanding and
so it's Belichick in a way so you know
Brady the whole a merit of of he's
searching for a little bit of freedom do
you think that that again you know
everybody seems to say yes from we've
spoken to Carson Palmer we've spoken to
Marshall Faulk who obviously knows about
Aryans from from me from the Colts days
as well so do you think that that is
something that Aryans and Brady will be
simpatico
I think they will as you said very
demanding very old-school you know you
Bruce came up under Bear Bryant so he's
not a stranger to discipline but the
difference is tom has spent 20 years
with the defensive coach now he's with
an offensive guy very very similar style
but different thought process Bruce has
created Bruce was going to push the ball
there they're gonna score point and I
think Tom's gonna enjoy that and
appreciate Tony Dungy football night in
America NBC Sports here on the Rich
Eisen show week before the draft what
what does a head coach do right now week
before I really have kind of your
thought process of what you'd like to
see happen you played out different
scenarios in your mind and now you just
want to be sure what's going to take
place and where you're gonna go I
remember coming up to the 2006 draft
write about this time kind of a week
before the draft
we Edgerrin James had signed in free
agency with Arizona we pretty much knew
we're going to take a running back I
think we're picking 29 and who's gonna
be there and you go through all these
different scenarios and for us it was
Joseph Addai Maurice jones-drew Laurence
Moroney we're going to get one of these
guys what if they're all there what if
none of them are there what if people
call you and two of them are there and
you can trade down what if a run goes on
running back so we need to trade up
those are the kind of things you start
to think about in this last month but
you you kind of have your eye on for
five guys in those first three round did
Peyton Manning ever give two cents on
this subject because I obviously never
not really he you know he obviously had
his thoughts and and he'd want to know
who was good who we were looking at but
it was never a type of thing where he'd
come in and said we ought to take this
guy now he'd had thoughts on on free
agency
I remember when Brandon Stokley became
available and he pounded the table hey
this guy thrown to him at the passing
Academy yeah better perfect slot
receiver for us guys that he had played
against and been around but as far as
the draft he kind of left that up the
bill well I mean and and so what is the
I guess what would be the sensitivities
of this because clearly Peyton Manning
knows football and clearly you want to
keep your guy happy and clearly you want
to have him feel included as opposed to
let us handle this Peyton and you play
football I mean he's never went that
route but I think in his mind he
understood that we were going to put the
team together we were going to get him
weaponry and we're gonna get good people
and I think he trusted bill that way and
may have had some conversations with him
but he he really trusted the process and
felt like we were going to get quality
people and good people so there wasn't a
whole lot of conversation before the
dress house sooner we picked a guy now
he wanted to know everything about him
what's his phone number when can I get
to him
I remember gas my last year coaching we
drafted Anthony Gonzales Ohio State was
you know and that system were they don't
get out of school until June so he was
without even talking to us he drove two
times a week to Columbus from
Indianapolis took the PlayBook up there
went over with Anthony threw balls
drove back and he did everything in his
power to make sure he was ready for
training camp so yeah once we got guys
he was all all on board so who's the guy
from your tenure either in Tampa or the
Colts that you are that you pounded the
table for in a draft and then you're
you're pleased with the result like the
the guy that you're like okay I I
believed in the kid and the kid balled
out you
an example for that well I'd say I'll
give you to work done was just Derrick
Brooks came into my office at the end of
the 96th season and he says you know we
need playmakers I played with this kid
he's great he's a great person he will
he will make us a playoff team and he
pounds the table to me for two months
and so our scouts like Warrick everybody
had the thought hey he's 175 pounds
maybe he can just be a returned guy
maybe he won't be a full-time guy and
once I kind of did the research and with
Derrick kind of pounded me then you know
I was sold and we ended up drafting work
in the first round and he was fantastic
for us and that was a little unusual we
got kid a little bit taking a little
small guy that high but he was
phenomenal the other side of the coin I
remember when Robert Mathis came out we
saw the highlight film other than Barry
Sanders best highlight film I've ever
seen millets later oh he was incredible
did everything at Alabama and made
tackles on the kickoff game block punch
sack the quarterback chase guys down you
know 50 yards downfield and incredible
but then you say well 6 foot 1 220
pounds where is he going to play
defensive end
maybe specialized guy and Bill Polian
watch more and more tape saw it and he
said hey this is just what you're
describing to me you said this is what
you want this is a guy we need to get so
we're in the in the fourth round of the
draft and he said we got a chance to
trade next year's fourth round pick to
get an extra 15 and take him and I was
like gosh I hate trade those future
picks that's your lifeblood and he said
you love this guy and that's a gift bill
I really do love my luck everything I've
seen I love the attitude he said we're
gonna give him a year early we're gonna
take next year's fourth round pick and
you're gonna have him for four year to
develop and we've got to do it so we did
we made a trade with Cleveland picked
him in the 5th brown and 126 later he's
probably going to the Hall of Fame so I
just kind of did the GPS thing on it
during your answer by looking it up on
the old Internet's over here
so you must have been in the Kansas City
draft process draft room with just I
guess to go full circle here with shot
never when you saw the Barry Sanders
tape what did Barry Sanders tape look
like Oh incredible we're having
discussions and yes if you remember Troy
Aikman and then there's very Sanders
Deion Sanders
honi Mandor it's Derek Thomas and so
we're you know we got these great
players that we're looking at what if it
goes this way what if it goes that way
and we had Kristin McCoy a and we had
running back and firs there and you know
this guy is there we got to take him and
you watch the tape and it was incredible
but then you watch Derek comma and Wow
so we knew we were gonna get a good
player but Barry Sanders was incredible
in college well I mean so Ariens that's
where he was the running backs coach
right there and so that was the end of
that he's like we got to go get him but
I kind of worked out for Derek Thomas
you were drafting fourth overall
I just called that one up and Dionne
went fifth Dionne tells a story all the
time Tony that this was back in the day
when the combine had no organization to
it in terms of who got to interview whom
and that and that you were just standing
outside of a hotel room door where the
player was inside interviewing with the
team and as soon as it came out it was a
total free-for-all to grab that guy go
yeah
Janos Dion was telling me that story and
he said he got pulled into a room and he
got pulled into a room by the Giants and
he asked where they drafted and he said
that the giant said eighteenth and he
goes oh you have no shot at me to give
this personality test oh it's like 200
questions so they get a guy and he's
being there 45 minutes or an hour and
and scouts would be just outside the
door waiting and yeah it was very very
frustrating no rules but yeah I can I
can sleep the answer that's where you've
got
at me and he walked out but that said
you're the D bat you're the defensive
backs coach for fourth overall did you
chat with Dino on that carmine did you
do it but kind of told him the same
thing
I don't think we're gonna take you don't
think we're gonna get you but you know
you don't know how things are going to
fall but yeah he was a special player
for sure so that's what you had you had
me watching Deion Sanders bill car
watching Derrick Thomas Bruce Arians
watching Barry Sanders and you know
Howard mud watching Tony Mann duritz and
Howard to his credit said hey we got a
chance to get one of these weapons
Tony mandarins can only block one guy
Barry Sanders can make ten guys myth and
score a touchdown we get a chance to
take very Sanders there's no way you can
say Tony Mack and everybody usually is
kind of you know sorting their own thing
out trying to make themselves get it
good and Howard said hey no I'm telling
you don't even think of Tony man because
he's got a chance to get one of these
other guys and it was I learned
something that's that year for sure I
bet you didn't I mean man what a staff
for Marty shot and Iraq in 89 before I
let you go you could take only one
player in this year's draft to would it
be
Tony Dungy in 2020 you know Joe furrow a
special but you know - you've got some
quarterbacks I love Justin Herbert with
the you know the origin connection so I
just think she's young if you got a
chance to get that special pass rusher
who everybody says really more dominant
than Nick Bolton and college
I like that pass rust like that you know
I mean we and again we just saw what
what San Francisco did and you know and
obviously what whatever what you can do
with a whole fresh set of fingers that
you could put in the dirt if you can
keep amassing those pass rushers and we
just saw DeForest Buckner winds up now
in Indianapolis everybody's trying
everybody's trying to replicate all that
Tony great chat man I really do
appreciate when you call in and look for
my call it's going to come more often we
are on the same team certainly since you
know you rejected the University of
Michigan years before I showed up
[Laughter]
that's my god but hey look it all worked
out for you at Minnesota and obviously
now with NBC you take care of Tony we'll
chat soon
all right you got it that is Tony Dungy
right here on the Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here